online can see my little face at the
bottom but I'm going to stand over here
so I can actually look out at the
audience
um hey okay so now what we have 12
people here we're making progress
anyways
um you know I I usually introduce the
speaker because I am chair of the
department right now
can you hear me okay
oh okay
um but I'm the speaker today so I guess
I will introduce myself I think you all
know me Bill Hirsch
um and um I think pretty much everyone
knows that I have made the decision uh
after 25 years of leading what was
originally the freestanding Division and
now the department uh to step down from
that role I'm not retiring
um I'm uh plan to continue doing my
teaching and research and I will
continue to be the chair until an
interim chair is named by the dean and
the executive committee which consists
of Karen Eden David door Shannon
McQueeney and Cindy Morris and Ann
Marshall the department administrator
will
um
meet with the dean at some point and um
a decision will be made I'd always hope
that we might quickly recruit a new
permanent chair but I think a
combination of about a half dozen other
departments at the University
um having interim chairs and plus the
financial circumstances of the
institution
um kind of mean that the interim chair
will probably be there for a year or
even potentially more
um and I will still be around and I look
forward to continuing all the
interactions and collaborations that I
have so I you know I usually kind of
kick off the research conference uh each
year and so I'll do it again this year I
usually I have a talk called state of
the program but I thought I thought that
this year
um that I would kind of share
um some history
um and so
um but but also to leave time for
discussion and if people want to make
comments about
um where they think the department
should go or or various other kinds of
things will be free to do that so
hopefully I only have maybe about
30 minutes most of slides
so um
okay
it's not advancing
okay there we go
um some of you probably saw this meme uh
last month and it was
and it was a particularly apropos to me
because
um uh you know as uh the the new um the
new chair of the um United Kingdom uh
King Charles
um uh you know in this fancy Garb and
then the the meme is that when you were
a Carefree tenured professor living your
best life and then suddenly forced to
chair your department so I'm kind of
going in the opposite direction I'm
although
you all know I never dressed that one
you know we dress pretty casually around
here but anyway so now I'm uh aiming to
become a Carefree tenured professor
so okay so what do I hope to do this
hour
um
go away
yeah well
okay anyways so first I'm going to
reflect a little bit on some of our
accomplishments and and these slides are
online I'm happy to share them with you
all they're on my website and then also
have any kind of discussion and it
really a start of a discussion and and
obviously the discussion will continue
when there's a new uh chair of the
department
so
um I know only one person in this room
who who was here pretty much from the
beginning
um so anyways um some of you may know
that um back in the 1980s there was a
Senator uh from Oregon Mark Hatfield
um who
um was a very senior senator very
esteemed and back then no matter what
political party you were in part of what
you did was bring home the bacon
earmarks and Hatfield actually because
he was somewhat of an anti-war
um Senator he's kind of a breed of
Republican that doesn't exist anymore
but we won't go into politics today
anyways he um he was very good at at
bringing earmarks to the universities
around Oregon including OHSU in fact
that's why the building next to us has
his name on it the Hatfield Research
Center in the mid-1980s he saw this in
initiative that was from the National
Library of Medicine a legitimate program
that had been approved by Congress the
integrated Advanced information
management system or Iams initiative and
he added to the appropriation in the mid
80s that
um 25 million dollars which was actually
a lot of money back then still a lot of
money would go to OHSU to build this
building
and to shore up
um actually the goal of Iams was to
establish computer networks because back
then it was not a given that Health Care
organizations had computer networks and
it turns out OHSU actually had one just
in the hospital so this would establish
a network the rest on the rest of the
campus and expand the library and
develop an academic informatics program
which you were supposed to do if you
competitively if you competed
successfully to get an Iams Grant so the
I am James Grant to OHSU was awarded
what they say non-competitively it was
in earmark but actually
um the the folks from nlm were a little
gassed at first Don limbert was the
director of the nlm back then and um
said to me many years later you know we
were initially really worried about this
but but you guys did what you're
supposed to do with the Iams program and
actually Joan Ash and I wrote a paper in
the mid 90s kind of describing that in
the um what was then the bulletin of the
medical Library Association so um OHSU
recruited the first direct so the Bic
would become a center the ICC the C
stands for Center even though now the
big is a building and
um uh uh uh a person who some of us in
this room know a guy named Bob Beck was
recruited from Dartmouth College and he
came along with Kent spackman and
Catherine Pyle who many of you know
who's still here
um and um they started the big and
um the the building this building opened
up in in 1991
um and the first occupant of the office
that I currently sit in Bic 517 was Dr
Beck now um unfortunately
um oh well let me and um so uh Dr Beck
came and part of his um package was that
you can recruit faculty so he recruited
these two assistant professors uh
straight out of Fellowship one was me
one was Mark Health band
um who by both of us are still here and
and both of us have our clinical
backgrounds in Internal Medicine so my
initial academic appointment was in the
department of medicine because the Bic
was a center so it's not an academic
program and
um we then recruited our first fellow
some physician out in Astoria
um who uh um came and became this was
before we had the nlm Grant and so um Dr
Gorman here was our first fellow
interestingly enough both he Mark and
myself are all from the Chicago area in
fact Mark and I went to kindergarten and
first grade together although we didn't
know each other then and we actually met
we were in medical school at University
of Illinois at the same time but we
didn't know each other we didn't meet
each other until we got here
one of the first things that Dr Beck did
was to apply for nlm funding I was out
of an nlm Fellowship that was in Boston
at Brigham and Women's one of the
Harvard teaching hospitals and
um OHSU was awarded the the beginnings
of the nlm t-15 grant that several of
you are funded by to this day and
initially we were funded only for
post-docs because we didn't have a PhD
program also at that time Joan Ash was
working in the library finishing her PhD
at Portland State and in system science
and Cindy Morris who's also upstairs on
the fifth floor was kind of a refugee
from the Department of medicine because
um at that time most researchers were
basic science researchers and Cindy's an
epidemiologist and obviously these days
very well accomplished and she kind of
fit in with the group so this is kind of
like the startup company any if you will
that began the the Bic and informatics
at OHSU
we then actually had a pretty
significant setback again some of you
might not be old enough to remember this
or maybe didn't live in Oregon but in
1990 Oregon voters approved uh measure
five a property tax limitation which
um significantly impacted the state
budget the first of many many OHSU
budget crises that I've been through but
anyways they actually had to renege on
some of the commitments to Dr Beck and
he ended up leaving basically leaving
myself and Kent spacman who was the
other person that came with him from
Dartmouth
as pretty much the the
um the faculty left here so Dr spackman
became uh the well he didn't I don't
think he had the titles director of the
book but anyways he was the second
occupant of my current office upstairs
but then we
um despite
um these challenges actually had a
number of early successes
um some of you know of K Awards K Awards
didn't exist back then um but NIH had
this thing called an r29 or our first
award which is actually more generous
than a k award
um I managed to get one of those in 1990
Dr Gorman in 95 and then in 97 we became
one of the uh hrq funded evidence-based
practice centers uh initially led by Dr
Hal fan now led by Roger chow and also
um Joan Ash got her start there's
actually a philanthropist that gave us a
small startup Grant and that uh
Pete Jones interest in studying uh what
at the time we called physician order
entry Poe eventually known as cpoe and
that led to her first um nlmr1 so so
despite the setback
um we were off and running
um as a group and in fact the dean of
the medical school at the time Dr Joseph
Bloom really noticed that that we were a
group and and really had no
institutional visibility and he's a
psychiatrist who knows very little about
informatics but he said you guys need to
form a unit so you have some visibility
and that led to in 1997 to the
establishment of the division of medical
informatics and outcomes research or DMI
or de Meyer as maybe we called it and I
was appointed as head of it
um Dr spackman at that point was not
really interested in leadership actually
he he became very involved in and snomed
the control terminology
and a number of other research areas and
then he retired about probably spent
about 15 years ago now but in any case
um at a fairly young age for a kind of
leader of an academic program I was kind
of thrust into this role because if I
didn't do it the whole thing would have
collapsed in fact I actually had some
colleagues who said you know if you'd
like we can try to find some way to have
you soft land at our institution in our
program but we were really committed to
continuing this so OHSU has this
construct called a freestanding division
which is basically like a department in
everything but name you you have a
budget you you answer to the dean as the
head of it
um you you have your own promotion and
tenure process so
um and then at that point the pieces of
the Bic were kind of carved out so um
the the library
um moved under the Provost uh the
library is originally under the director
of the Bic the um the kind of computer
network on the can on the University
side that had formed by then
um merged with the hospital computer
network which made a lot of sense and
and that entity was renamed as you all
know it now as itg the information
Technology Group and so they
um
so it became a single uh Network
um actually a little one trivia I can
tell you about the network in the early
days you could pick your email address
that's why if you've ever sent me email
you notice I'm just Hirsch at ohsu.edu
because that's what I chose
um if I were to come to OHSU today I
would be Hirsch W because now it's your
last name plus your first initial so we
had a lot more uh control and there were
very few people around campus on the
internet then
um in fact I didn't put in the slides
here but we actually brought up the
first OHSU web server because itg didn't
really know what the web was this new
thing in the mid 90s called the web
anyway so then so the pick was now no
longer center it's a building and it's
been a building since then
um and most of us uh moved our faculty
appointments so
um I moved mine from the Department of
Medicine to this new freestanding
Division and
um and then because I was head of it I
became the third occupants of Vic 517
and at some point when when the new
chair interim or permanent decides can
can occupy that office so then of course
we really wanted to become a department
in the school of medicine and it it took
a little bit longer than we had hoped
but in 2003
um uh Joe Robertson who was the dean at
that point
established the department we used that
opportunity to change the name uh the
second part of the name to clinical
epidemiology because the term outcomes
research was kind of falling out of
favor and clinical epidemiology really
kind of describes more broadly what they
that side of the department does now
interestingly enough we very rarely use
medical informatics anymore
um but on the other hand it's a great
acronym D mice you know and everyone now
around campus in those demice so I don't
know that we would ever want to change
it but you know now typically we use
biomedical informatics biomedical and
health informatics Etc and so I was then
appointed the first chair and then I've
been the one and only chair of this
department that's another reason why I
would like to step down to give others
opportunities for for leadership
um another thing that I learned along
the way you know when I started you know
I trained in medicine and I went and did
a nlm informatics Fellowship
um after I trained in Internal Medicine
and I figured I would be a faculty at an
academic Medical Center and
um I looked at a few jobs but actually
OHSU was the
um the I thought had the best long-term
opportunity so that's why I came here
even I said first time ever set foot in
Oregon was my job interview I grew up in
the Chicago area and did my fellowship
in Boston
um and you know I got that our 29 grants
and I was doing my research and
information retrieval but I was always a
little bit interested in teaching and
education but I never realized it and so
it turns out
um that the masters of Public Health
Program started uh back in the early
1990s
um and um actually Ken spackman arrangs
for an elective in their program to to
basically be an introductory informatics
course and that that actually is the
beginnings of what's known as BMI 510
and and 10 by 10 I'll talk about that in
a moment for those who don't know
um and um Kent I think did it for like a
year and then he's like I don't want to
do this anymore I'm like oh I'll do it
and um
um I have literally been teaching that
introductory course for
you know almost 30 years now
um and um because I'm very meticulous
about backing up my data I I have the
handouts and the slides it'd be a great
um dissertation project someday for a
PhD student to do a kind of content
analysis of the whole thing going
forward in fact I've actually I'll show
you on the next Slide the curriculum
from the first time that I led the
course
um around that time
um there was interest
not only for me but I was very
interested in in pushing it and actually
I had some nice mentorship from Leslie
Hallock who was the Provost at the time
she retired from OHSU and about 10 years
ago became the president of Pacific
University in fact she retired from that
last year
um and she was very helpful uh not So
Much from the informatics standpoint but
navigating the whole state approval
process which we had to go through and
we started planning our first graduate
program which we thought we would start
with a master's degree and including the
possibility
um that nlm post docs could do the
Master's Degree so it was called master
of science and medical informatics it
got approved and in 1996 we opened our
doors and seven students arrived we
actually had some funding to actually
pay all of their tuition for like the
first year or two and and that got us
started and we started teaching in this
room
um
and um the courses in the department had
the minf prefix so my introductory
course changed from public health 549 to
minf 510 and we had our first graduates
of the program in um 1998 and um that
was the first time I actually ever went
to OHSU graduation and um I've gone
almost every year since then and um I I
make it a point to go as some of you
know so I don't know if anyone can read
this
um so this is actually this is a Word
document you know word won't open up
documents that are this old this is from
1993.
um but I was able to open it in textedit
and then copy the text out anyways you
probably can't read it but it's really
interesting to look at the topics
medical decision making medical data and
information announced there's nothing in
there about electronic health records
there there is about expert systems and
decision support tools which is kind of
what we how we describe AI although 1993
was the well into the AI winter that
kind of the the depth of the first
generation of AI but people were still
building expert systems and building
clinical decision support into
electronic health records but there's
nothing there about health information
exchange or machine learning or anything
like that but I just thought I'd show
that to you let me see how I'm doing
time wise okay well then
um this uh our success
um and and I it's clearly a team effort
I was at the head of it but um I never
would have been able to do it by myself
so um we we did a lot of other things
um many of these um that that were came
out of my passion for Education
um one was even in the late 1990s people
started asking can we take your courses
online and
um I I was always interested in
educational technology so we actually
converted minf 510 to an online format
in fact we used to offer two completely
separate sections of it and um the fall
of 1999 was actually the first offering
of that course online and then we
thought
um and then the the people who took it
you know can we take more we didn't
actually think initially that people
would want to get a full master's degree
online so that's why we created The
Graduate certificate
um and then so that too we had to
Shepherd through the state approval
process and it launched in 2000.
um we had always wanted to add a PhD
program and there were enough faculty by
then to do so and so we um
when we did the renewal for the the nlm
T15 in 2000 must have been in 2001
because it was funded in 2002 and it's
funded every five years it's 2022 we
just started the seventh cycle
um so the the t-15 was renewed actually
with for the first time we asked for
pre-doctoral slots
um in anticipation of the PHD program
um another thing that happened that year
was
um because there was enough interest in
in the um in having an online Master's
Degree we went ahead and put the whole
master's program online and we um we set
it up as a non-thesis masters at that
point a lot of people were talking about
professional master's degree I mean they
still do but that that term was used a
lot so it would be a non-thesis master
of medical informatics or MMI
um so then in 2000 so then also we were
once we got the nlm grant renewed we
started working on building and getting
approved the PHD program and that was
approved in 2003 and we used that
opportunity to at least move change the
name of the educational program not the
department but the educational program
became biomedical informatics meaning
that my introductory course now became
BMI 510. and um so we started
um uh doing that uh we we had a we had a
growing number of bioinformatics courses
um before Shannon was here
um a guy named Chris Dube uh was on our
faculty and developed some of those
courses but it was really Shannon who
kind of
um really took took the reins and uh we
really created a whole new track in the
program called
um bioinformatics and computational
biology or BCB which some of you are in
and
um and Shannon was the head of that
track
we
um we actually I didn't I should mention
it there we we changed the name of the
other track initially to clinical
informatics
um the the one that we now call hcin
I'll get to that in a moment
um one of our first PhD students was a
real go-getter and he came from Stanford
and he had a lot of courses graduate
courses under his belt already so was
able to to whiz through and also set the
bar really high for the PHD program so
Adam Wright who now is a professor
biomedical informatics at Vanderbilt has
done amazing work over the years in
clinical decision support he was our
first PhD graduate
um and and then also in 2007 Dr Speckman
finally he decided at that point I don't
want to do the uh nlm Grant anymore so
that with that cycle that that must have
started in 2006 I became the pi of the
nlm grant
um and another thing we did and you can
see from that lower picture is that we
hosted the nlm trainees meeting that
some of you went to and I see Jennifer
won an award at and
um we were were actually most of you
know we're supposed to host it again in
2020 but there's a pandemic that came
along and kabashed that so we actually
put on a virtual nlm meeting and then I
just just my mentioning of going to
graduation that this picture is from
2002. you can see Paul there Cindy
Morris myself Karen Judy Logan who
um is an Emeritus member of our faculty
and was a graduate in the very first
master's degree class she was a
physician and then did the master's
program and then joined our faculty and
taught courses and did research for many
years and then retired about five or
seven years ago and Joan so
um
I I was digging through my archives for
pictures and I came across this one
um so and then
um I could go on and on at about the
about the uh educational accomplishments
I'll just uh mention some of the
highlights so
um some of you know that I also am
involved in this program with the
American medical informatics association
called 10 by 10 and Amia our
professional association wanted to have
an online course and they talked to
vendors that wanted to charge them an
arm and a leg and by 2005 we had already
been teaching BMI 510 online for a half
decade so I said to my colleagues in
Amia why don't we take this course and
and repackage it as a standalone course
and
um we had to involve the lawyers a
little bit just to kind of set the terms
of the agreement and basically came up
with this mutually non-exclusive thing
where Amia could have other 10 by 10
courses and then
um
we would keep the intellectual property
of the BMI 510 course and that worked
out really well a Wida Congressman
um in the he actually resigned in
disgrace but in the in the 2000s uh
actually introduced in the
2009 2008 2009
um Congressional session
H.R 461 the 10 000 Train by 2010 act and
it actually passed the house but it
never got taken up in the Senate so
um uh but it would have kind of
established funding for training and
informatics but the the big thing that
happened and in fact I was just at a
meeting last week in Nashville hearing
Physicians complain about appropriately
so complain about how awful their ehrs
are
um and you know that all was facilitated
by the high-tech act and I really looked
back and I I think probably one of the
biggest historical events for our field
was the high-tech act
which as probably you all know was part
of the American Recovery and
reinvestment act because
um the economy was tanking and Barack
Obama had just become president as well
that was that was time ago
um and um house resolution one hr1 was
The Recovery Act that had
um the high-tech act embedded within it
because they were looking for shovel
ready projects and at that point there
was a lot of research that had come out
that showed that clinical decision
support ehrs could reduce errors
potentially save money
make health care more efficient you know
of course as we look back in retrospect
it didn't totally work out that way but
anyways the high-tech act
provided 30 billion dollars in
incentives for institutions including
OHSU to adopt electronic health records
OHSU actually already had epic by then
um but you you could still get the money
if you met the meaningful use criteria
um I think one of the only times a Dean
has ever called me into their office was
when the dean called me and said what's
this high-tech act and meaningful use
and how can we get this 13 million
dollars that would come to OHSU
um I would like to think that he would
have called me in for other more
important things anyways
um so in addition to the 30 billion
there was actually a hundred and
eighteen million for Workforce
Development and some of that was
actually influenced by some of the
research and writings that that I had
done
um honestly
um in fact people thought the whole
thing was wired for OHSU but it wasn't
but we we did we wrote the grants
um just like everyone else and they went
through a competitive review process and
um we were awarded
um 5.8 million dollars um there were
five curriculum Development Centers to
develop the onc health I.T curriculum
them they then designated a national
training and dissemination Center to
work and this these curricula were
developed for these short-term training
programs in community colleges
um we were appointed the National
Training and dissemination Center
um and then also we got additional
funding from the university-based
training which gave additional funding
mostly for kind of graduate certificate
kind of work and um and also our MBI
program
um so this um for for the few years
starting around 2010 that this was a
major part of my life
um and um you know I mean I look back on
it now it's it you know it's almost a
decade ago but it really was uh uh
amazing time
anyway so the the um the high-tech act
funding ended and we continued on
um we were able to add some things to
the program to expand it actually like
Virginia lankies who unfortunately
um uh has retired
um she came about through this some of
the other things we had done so some of
the legacy of it lives on
um another and this history is
incomplete but I I'm just pointing to
some real high highlights here another
big highlight
um was um I see some of our CI fellows
here uh um when the new
clinical informatics sub-specialty
Fellowship for Physicians was launched
um you know we were involved in that
from the get-go we were one of the first
four Fellowship programs funded
um in the at the very beginning I was
the program director but the intent
always was for Vishnu to direct the
program and he's done a tremendous job
with it I guess one other
um thing I can point to is
um in 2018 the the Provost decided that
our tracks were actually really distinct
programs and said you should call these
Majors so that's when we changed
clinical informatics to hcin and that's
why those of you in eight Cyan are in
the hcin major and those of you in BCB
are in the BCB major and we also I I
lobbied Shannon to change the
computational biology the computational
biomedicine which I think she wanted to
do
um but in any case um we did that
we've had a lot of other great
educational grants over the years just
to mention a few of these so again some
of you may have been around long enough
but for a while we had a bunch of
Physicians from Argentina pretty much as
nlm fellows they they did the same kind
of Fellowship that was a grant from the
NIH Fogerty International Center to
develop Global Health informatics
there was one more round of onc funding
to update the curriculum in around 2015
and in fact those one of the unfortunate
things about curriculum development
grants is if there's not resources to
keep the curriculum developed it just
sits there and gets stale so you can
click on that link and you can go see
this curriculum that is about four or
five years old now
um we also uh about it must have been
what about
uh almost eight years ago the um the
first of the many NIH forays into big
data and data science so NIH had a
program big data to knowledge bd2k and
um we did we got some additional
curriculum development funded
um and also
um got a second grant that was led by
David door to develop a skills course
and
um so and actually Melissa Handel who
some of you know who's no longer here
she was involved in this Shannon was
also involved and we developed this big
data curriculum and it too sits out
there on our website but
um not really kept up to date
um one other Grant I would point to
that's not in our department
but um what's important to us is the the
AMA Grant the uh and the American
Medical Association Grant uh um uh that
um the AMA
um you know historically was like the
Physicians Trade union but actually in
the last uh decade or so AMA has gotten
interested in medical education and even
physician well-being and things like
that but they they funded these
educational these uh uh accelerating
change in medical education grants and
um Paul and I managed to convince George
McConnell to put a piece in there about
informatics and and actually Dr mayak
Hano who actually just left OHSU
um was really the first
um educational Dean to kind of open the
door of the MD curriculum to
um uh clinical informatics and and so
that was a great opportunity
um and and actually
um a bunch of I see Gretchen uh back
there too a bunch of these grants kind
of uh
worked out well for her and she
continues to so
yes we have very much benefited from
having Gretchen um uh maintaining the
medical school curriculum and doing
other things in the department anyways
this was a big deal because back in the
90s I you know I used to say well we
should our you know medical students
should know something about informatics
and the you know we'll go talk to the
course director's Bill and then the
course directors would say well no you
know yeah it's probably important but
not in my course or
um you know we don't have room for it in
my course or another thing I got is oh
they're all digital natives you know
they know how to do instant messenger
and email and it's like no that's not
informatics and um but it was finally Dr
May Kano who opened the door for us
um so where are we today I guess I'm
taking a little bit longer than I had uh
planned but anyways
um uh so
um we have students who take our classes
actually all over the world
um actually this map is a little old but
David door generated this uh probably
about seven or eight years ago from
taking the I think the ZIP codes of our
online students
um I always periodically take pictures
of the even though we don't always
publish these in paper anymore but all
the Theses and dissertations and we are
closing in on a thousand degrees and
certificates awarded
um mostly hcn but but still plenty of
BCB and um so we continue to move along
um my 10 by 10 course has also been a
success you know it's 10 by 10 stood for
10 000 trained by 2010 because we
started in 2005. we didn't hit 10 000 I
I never thought we would but it was kind
of an aspirational goal but there was
continued interest in it particularly
after the high-tech act and just this
year we have surpassed 3 000 people who
have done 10 by 10 and those people who
take this course can actually take the
BMI 510 exam and get and if they get a
sufficiently high grade get credit for
BMI 10 BMI 510 and use that to enroll in
the hcin program and um many of us
probably several hundred or maybe not
several maybe two or three hundred over
the years now maybe more like 200 at
most anyways
um so um
um the introductory course has also
um uh been uh successful in other ways
so
um I had uh the Dean's office go into
banner and generated report on everyone
who's taken BMI 510 and all of its
predecessors and so we're now like over
1600 of all time we've done some other
kind of customized offerings and
um at the beginning of the pandemic uh
when the Dean's office and other medical
school started saying we we need virtual
learning opportunities for medical
students so you know I have this one
size fits all and it turns out it it
fits nicely into a two-week block for
medical students and so in the early
days of the pandemic a couple hundred
medical students from 17 students
finally I I had to say enough
um but it's still available as an
elective to medical students and I have
a few who are in the course right now
um
and um I think another Testament of our
success people some of you can see your
names on this are um and and this I hope
this list is complete I apologize if I
missed anyone
um but these are all the people uh who
have done the educational program and
are now faculty in some way some of them
are adjunct affiliate some are Emeritus
um but we have had graduates before the
nlm fellowship
um the nln postdoc Aaron is sitting
there
um the Master's Degree that's how Vishnu
came into the program then we finally
started having pre-doc
um PhD students join the faculty uh the
clinical informatics Fellowship to uh so
far of the graduates of that
um and then and even though he didn't do
informatics training I felt I should put
David's name here he did his Internal
Medicine Residency here and he um so he
trained at OHSU although not in
informatics we couldn't convince him to
stay he went off to the University of
Utah
he didn't elect him okay great okay and
again I apologize if this list is not
complete
um so you know I also I've said a lot
about education I also do research most
of you know I do research and
information retrieval
um I'm proud of my H Google Scholar H
index of 76 it is now
um I published this book oh and actually
I forgot to mention on on this slide I
took over the editorship of this book
from Dr Robert Hoyt and we just
published the eighth edition you can go
look at it upstairs there's a copy of it
sitting
um on Monica's desk
um and you could even buy it if you want
and um uh the uh so in addition to a lot
of uh articles and so forth I published
that um I've also had this passion about
information retrieval and
um and actually I had I was already
working on it when the pandemic hit and
I finished it up at the fourth edition
um in 2020
um that was um published in mid-2020 so
once the pandemic hit I had a lot of
time to work on it
so um just a few things about the
department
um that um I I think it's safe to say
that we are recognized nationally and
internationally as leaders in biomedical
informatics and clinical epidemiology
um I didn't I haven't said much about
the evidence-based Practice Center which
actually tomorrow is having an event to
celebrate its 25th anniversary which was
the same year we became the freestanding
division that's when they first got
their funding
um many faculty have been successful and
we'll have to find a way someday to
summarize all that we do have the four
Vice chairs of the department that I
mentioned at the beginning and of course
we
um nothing would happen in this
department without the tremendous uh
administrative staff led by um Ann who's
the department administrator and Andrew
who heads up the educational program and
all the people who work under them and I
will state their names but I know I'm
going to forget someone but under Ann is
is Monica Alicia are currently unfilled
financial analyst person and then under
Andrea is
um Lynn and Lauren and Vanessa and am I
forgetting anyone I probably am I'm just
kind of thinking of the deaths upstairs
anyways and I suppose another person who
should be mentioned here although she's
also faculty is Catherine Pyle who has
an administrative role in in helping us
apply for our grants but she also
teaches our scientific writing course so
all of those people are really the the
what keeps the department going
um I'm also proud of the fact that we
have a very sustained strong record of
uh research grant funding you actually
see that one Peak which is right around
the high tech act because not only did
we get the the educational grants but
there was a lot of money thrown into
research at that time so like many units
we went back down but we continued to
um Trend back upwards and all told the
department has generated over 200
million dollars in grant funding since
1997.
I would also point out that our t-15
training Grant is the largest and second
longest running training Grant at OHSU
and there are
um if you count the summer interns and
some of the other people have been
funded actually 131 trainees and the
grant over the years has brought in 22
million dollars so
um we're we're good for the Oregon
economy
so
um I had hoped to finish a little bit
sooner but that's okay
um so some of you might ask well what
are you going to do bill now that you're
no longer a chair
um and um I have plenty to do I I plan
to continue all my teaching and research
so I will continue teaching the
introductory course
um some of you know I have an r01 that
with Steve bedric
um and um collaborators at Mayo Clinic
and University of Texas Houston that's
funded through 2026 to look at
information retrieval applied to patient
records for cohort identification
um last year I was awarded uh in
collaboration with the University of
Cape Town uh part a grant from nih's
data science Initiative for Africa I'll
actually be in Cape Town in a few weeks
um obviously there is the training Grant
I will in fact hopefully have more time
for that some of you also know we were
just awarded an r25 from the nlm because
the NIH rules changed around summer
interns we can't fund them with the
training Grant so nlm has had a separate
r25 call for proposals we managed to get
funded and um so that will continue our
r25 with a particular focus on
historically underrepresented students
in the field there there's a component
with Portland State and the build exit
out program
um and then that's probably enough to
keep me going but I also have my
collaborations I'm involved with Karen's
mammo screen project Aaron and I collab
operate we've we've managed to
get some industry funding the last
several years to look at
searching for rare diseases through EHR
data
Jeff gold and Vishnu Mohan have a EHR
simulation grant that I'm involved with
and then another grant that was that
just came to the department that David
door is our OHSU
lead in this new bridge to AI initiative
there you may have seen the press
release that was in OHSU now a week or
two ago so
um when I'm no longer a chair I will
still have plenty to do
so at some point I will just delete out
I'll just be Professor but for right now
I'm still chair so I'm gonna stop at
this point and open the floor to any
comments questions
um I can look and see if there's
anything in the chat
um
let's see
[Music]
um
uh Kate has a cliff notes version a
history of D mice
um and um this is contributions to zoom
backgrounds anyways
um so
um thank you for indulging me and
listening to this and um you know it's
it's been a lot of fun and and I hope to
keep building on it and I hope that the
new leadership will have the opportunity
to keep things growing so any comments
or
um
suggestions yeah I had a slide
pick up where people
yeah right yeah
the other is um
us with all our
memories yeah
[Music]
sure right yeah yeah absolutely yeah
Peter MB he's probably our most
distinguished graduate he's now the
chair of informatics at Vanderbilt
well not not a black hole but a um they
yeah yeah yeah they they suck everything
in they do a great job of it
kudos to them
congratulations to you when I first came
here
you fly her into the computer
's Comfort said ohc which I'm going to
do and then I went to meet Bob back and
he said he had these two people he had
recruited
so I should come to a fellowship my name
was Mark Halford yeah yeah
he you know actually another thing I I
there there's plenty of other things I
could put in you know what Bob Beck was
very enamored by the next machine you
know that was the com that was the
computer that Steve Jobs when he left
Apple
um initially you know he of course
eventually came back but
um the next machine and and Bob Beck had
bought like 50 of them or something like
that and they were all over the place
and we were using them
I'm mostly stuck with my Mac but
do you mean the evidence-based Practice
Center
no no no well pcori is a is a national
program pikori it funds patient-centered
outcomes research also known as
comparative effectiveness research it's
a it's a actually it's a
actually you guys probably know more
than I do it's a it's a
yeah quasi it's actually funded from the
Affordable Care Act
um
so Obamacare
yeah yeah yeah
okay so yeah pcori's a separate thing
there now the evidence-based Practice
Center is currently called the Pacific
Northwest evidence-based Practice Center
because they have collaborators up in
Seattle
um but that's not all of clinical
epidemia it's a large part of clinical
epidemiology but it's not all of it all
of the work that Annette does is also
well and it also bleeds over into
informatics
yeah drug yeah that that yeah that
project doesn't exist anymore but the
there were related to the evidence-based
Practice Center 15 states and the
province of Ontario
um kind of banded together to do
evidence-based reviews of drug
categories and um
yeah for Medicaid programs and we did a
lot of them or did we do all of them
yeah yeah and um so that was a big uh
Mary McDonough that was uh who another
person who recently well not that
retired last year
um was the head of that
so let's see
Homer Chan Homer Chen who's also been a
fixture in informatics in um Portland
he's one of our uh affiliate faculty it
was for many years the head of
um uh was he wasn't called it but he's
basically the cmio of the local Kaiser
who's the medical director for
informatics or something like that and
when Kaiser was spending like a billion
dollars with IBM trying to build a
medical record Homer was up here
implementing this thing called epic and
of course now that's what's used all
throughout Kaiser and and he's made many
contributions to our program so thank
you Homer thank you for your kind kind
words
um and um yeah Vishnu mentions that uh
running into D mice alumni I do as well
I also run into 10 by 10 like numerous
times I've been like in an airport to
someone hey Bill I took 10 by 10 from
you three years ago and they don't have
their name tag on so I can't remember
exactly who they are but um you know as
you all know OHSU is very well known in
informatics and
that will hopefully benefit especially
the trainees when they go looking for
jobs and so forth
Bill knows everyone and I mean I know a
lot of people that is true
organization
friends of Bill as we used to say in the
1990s a different bill yeah in Thailand
yeah sure
please just go
yeah yes you know um well I guess we're
broadcasting publicly but but maybe
because I'm Advanced enough in my career
I can error some well it's not really
dirty laundry it's just an opinion
um one of the well many some people
argue there's many unfortunate things
about the transition from Vista to
Cerner but one of the clear unfortunate
things is that Vista the electronic
health record for the VA is like is
unlike almost any other government I.T
project you know most government I.T
projects are done from the top down I
mean that that's why the Obamacare
website failed because they came up with
the specifications and they they hired
you know some I.T firm and they did it
wrong and there were other problems too
um but the the VA the Vista system
really benefited from this Rich
informatics Community throughout the VA
system and they're still mostly there
um but you know what happened here when
they saw Cerner coming they just didn't
think they needed that anymore which I
think was a terrible mistake
um and um so a number
um uh Blake lessoroth was someone who
left
um fortunately Alicia is still here
um and um but you know I think it's
unfortunate that
um there could be some really good
Fellowship actually not only clinical
informatics Fellowship but all
opportunities for all of our students to
do things that the VA even to be part of
the new transition which they're not
that much a part of
um uh is is unfortunate so we'll see
what happens with the VA I mean it's you
know the Portland VA was supposed to be
the third VA for Cerner and it was
supposed to be live in 2020 and what did
they saying now 23 I think they're
talking about so yeah Aaron I think
there are still opportunities yeah
yes that yes that's right
yeah data analytics yeah yeah
right
they were
regular yeah
that's cool
are built around
that
hey there isn't so it's built around
the workings of people in the
information
regulate wrong you didn't have this
underlying framework
capture buildings that could have
something in Residence
yeah you know actually the Vista
actually has its warts you know it's
it's not as standards based as it could
be
um there's a few other issues you know
some people say it's older technology
although it sits on top of mumps which
is also what epic sits on top of
um the um but yeah no you're right there
are and there are kind of data
analytical kinds of opportunities that
the VA like what janji does like what
eilish does and I leash has a big new
sleep Grant so there's a lot of
opportunity but the opportunity to do
kind of care and feeding of the EHR is
unfortunately I don't think is is there
as at least as much as it used to be and
and you know the the VA system really
evolved because there was this
Grassroots
Country-Wide you know almost every major
VA you know had an informatics
um physician and and and and and other
in informaticians and some of you know
some of those folks are very distributed
yeah and iterative yeah yeah exactly
almost and and technically it is open
source but um it's not like you can just
download it or run it but um it it kind
of had the flavor of an open source
thing where you know Portland would
develop a new
sepsis module or something like that and
and then the national VA might decide to
incorporate it into the system there's I
see um so Kate asks them how difficult
is it for an outsider I actually think
we're a pretty friendly group
um and um
um you know we uh we we you know we go
to meetings like Amia and meet with
people and
um you know we we always try to and and
this year we'll be putting on a dessert
reception at the ABM meeting and we
invite all of our
students and alumni and friends of Bill
um
and uh so for any of you who are going
to the APM meeting it's it's on Monday
night at eight o'clock and um you know
you're welcome to come
um and then this year I'm actually I'm
also inviting all of the people who
contributed chapters to the the new
edition of the book
anything else
that's actually we are actually about at
the hour so okay well again thank you
all for listening and um you know like I
said I will we'll be around and um I I
like you will wait for the white smoke
to come out of the chimney on the top of
the building when the new
we'll see okay see you all later bye-bye
yeah you know when the